this is a zenpic it's a drug approved by
the FDA to manage type 2 diabetes maybe
you've heard the jingle
or maybe you've seen ozempic in the news
recently for another reason weight loss
weight loss easy weight loss maybe it's
called diet drug Miracle weight loss
drug and it's true ozempic was designed
to help people manage their blood sugar
but it's also proven to help people lose
weight my doctor was like this is mainly
for blood sugar management but as a side
effect like you will lose weight when I
started to notice that like in the first
month or so I had dropped 10 pounds like
nothing I was like there's something to
this and once you learn why it works
you'll understand how this drug could
completely change the way we approach
weight loss
according to the latest data from the
National Institutes of Health around 42
percent of adults in the U.S are
currently categorized as obese the cdc's
list of health risks associated with
obesity include heart disease stroke and
type 2 diabetes diseases that rank among
the leading causes of premature death
worldwide not everyone living with type
2 diabetes is considered obese but the
two are closely Linked In fact one of
the leading recommendations for managing
type 2 diabetes is weight loss even like
a small amount of weight reduction for
people with diabetes can help blood
sugar management I'm Mila Clark I'm 33
years old and I have a type of Diabetes
called latent autoimmune diabetes in
adults I reached out to Mila because she
runs a YouTube channel the hangry woman
where she makes videos about living a
healthy life with diabetes the thing
that I wish that people understood more
is how difficult it is to live with both
diabetes and obesity she's also
documented with ozempic it has always
been really hard for me to lose weight
despite diet and exercise and paying
attention to Lifestyle habits for a long
time doctors have had mixed views on how
to make weight loss more accessible to
help people lower their risk for
illnesses like type 2 diabetes one
option is weight loss medication
historically weight loss drugs have been
associated with dangerous side effects
and have been pulled from the market
metabolic bariatric surgery is extremely
effective for weight loss but it
requires dramatic lifestyle changes that
can be challenging to maintain but with
new diabetes drugs like ozempic
scientists have a safe and effective
tool for weight loss and it's based on
something that's inside our bodies
already hormones
hormones are the body's Messengers
running from one place to another
prompting certain cells into action when
we eat our bodies produce a bunch of
hormones to Aid in the process of
digestion one of them is glp-1 the
hormone that tells us when we're full
this is the sequence of amino acids that
make it up and this is semaglitide the
generic name for ozempic it's made to
mimic glp-1
here's why when food enters your stomach
and begins to work its way through the
digestive system your body releases
glp-1 in the intestine there are
receptors for glp-1 in cells all
throughout the body that serve different
functions when triggered by the hormone
in the pancreas glp-1 receptors promote
the production of insulin the hormone
that lowers blood sugar levels and
suppress the production of glucagon the
hormone that raises blood sugar levels
this is important for people with type 2
diabetes whose bodies are insulin
resistant and produce very little
insulin of their own synthetic insulin
is a critical treatment for blood sugar
management and somaglotide makes the
insulin you do have whether it's
produced naturally or synthetically work
better in your body losing excess fat
can also help you become more insulin
sensitive that's where glp-1's next
receptor comes in in the stomach glp-1
receptors slow gastric emptying which
means food doesn't move through the
digestive system as quickly and you stay
Fuller for longer it slows the digestion
of your food which overall helps with
blood sugar spikes and it helps you feel
Fuller for longer so you don't eat as
much and maybe most importantly at least
in regard to weight loss there are glp-1
receptors in the brain particularly in
the hypothalamus that suppress hunger
cravings that polar satiety healing for
longer is really helpful the digestive
system is designed to do all of this
naturally but glp-1 based medications
are made to amplify the hormone's
numerous health effects and it works a
major clinical trial of semaglitide in
adults showed an average weight
reduction of around 15 percent when
paired with an adjusted diet and
exercise routine compared to a placebo
group which demonstrated a little over
two percent weight reduction that level
of Effectiveness Rivals the results of
metabolic bariatric surgery and the fact
that I was able to take a once weekly
injection and then all of a sudden like
the pounds just like dropped off I was
like this is wild to me these drugs
aren't without side effects the most
common being nausea and gastrointestinal
effects like diarrhea Mila initially
stopped taking ozempic because of a side
effect that gave her heart palpitations
but she's back on it now and so far so
good my blood sugars are great I'm
having an easier time losing weight and
I've like amped up my exercise in being
outdoors and hiking and running and
walking and you don't do all of the
other things that everyone has to do to
be able to lose weight it just makes it
a little bit easier but it's helping me
so much with my diabetes management the
number of prescriptions of semaglitide
has risen dramatically since becoming
available in late 2017 and in 2021 the
FDA approved semacletide to be
prescribed at a higher dose for weight
management specifically branded under
the name wegovi it was big news and led
to this drug getting a lot of attention
sort of all at once the messaging
started to Center more around weight
loss than it did diabetes which is
unfortunate for people with diabetes and
people living with obesity there are
these two groups of people who really
need this drug for health purposes but
it's being trivialized you kind of
looked at as like oh this is an easy
weight loss solution there are solutions
in place now to deal with the sudden
high demand for these drugs for people
who need them mountjaro another
medication developed specifically for
type 2 Diet diabetes is currently being
fast-tracked for approval by the FDA to
be prescribed for weight loss too now
that ozempic's notoriety helps
somaglitide go mainstream it and drugs
like it will only become more commonly
prescribed for weight management it's
not as simple people as take this
injection and you won't be living with
obesity anymore or you will reverse your
diabetes but as a community we get
really excited to see Innovations happen
and tools that can make our lives a
little easier and that can cause less
diabetes burnout and helps you think
about diabetes less it's one of those
things that I think all of us want to
protect at all costs
[Music]
thank you